This is where we left off in the previous video.
We mounted plant cells and animal cells on
slides to observe them under the microscope.
Let us study them in general in this video.
For our convenience let us select just one…say
the onion peel cells to understand the structure
and the contents of the cells.
Roughly, we have these thick, distinct borders
that differentiate each cell from the other
one!
Then we have these tiny dark spots scattered all over!
Also, we can spot this prominent, circular
structure here which is very darkly stained.
Any idea what these things are?
Well, these are the cell constituents.
Let us get introduced to each.
This outer margin seen here is called the CELL WALL.
If we zoom in a bit, we notice that there
is another layer on the inner side of this
cell wall.
This is called the cell MEMBRANE.
Yes, the outer wall is the cell wall and the
inner layer is called the cell MEMBRANE.
The cell membrane is also referred to as the
PLASMA membrane.
It is POROUS in nature.
Hold on… what does ‘porous’ mean?
It simply means that “any material can move
in and out of the plasma membrane”.
But isn’t that dangerous?
Of course it is!
But the simple solution lies in the nature
of the plasma membrane.
That is because it is ‘SELECTIVELY PERMEABLE’.
Now what does selectively permeable mean here?
Just like a guard standing at the office door
who allows only members with identity cards
to enter and exit, the plasma membrane also
allows only SPECIFIC materials to move across.
We will look at this in details in our upcoming video.
This was just to understand how the plasma
membrane is selectively permeable!
Now let us move ahead to know about the cell wall.
Do you think ALL cells have cell walls?
Well the answer is a no!
That is because animal cells do NOT have cell walls.
An animal cell only has the plasma membrane
and not the cell wall.
The ‘cell walls’ act as PROTECTORS for plant cells.
It is composed of a NON-LIVING rigid structure
that is CELLULOSE.
It not only acts as a protector but also gives
a proper SHAPE to the plant cells.
It also helps in cell-to-cell interactions
and provides a barrier to undesirable macromolecules.
It protects, it gives shape to the cells,
and it helps in cell to cell interactions!
Clearly, the cell wall is a VERY important
part of the plant cell structure.
Now let’s get into this lighter region here.
This lighter region is the CYTOPLASM.
It is a jelly like substance filling up the cell space.
And these tiny parts in the cytoplasm are the organelles.
And what exactly are they?
Just like the human body has different organs,
the cell has various organelles.
And just like the organs, each organelle performs
a different function.
Let us study each organelle and its functions
in our upcoming videos!